ten seconds until kickoff warzone rated
57 players 1919 average rating time
handicapped 30 minutes experience level
30 to enter here we go alright double
those points and let's we're all here
okay I am playing the Sicilian and I am
under the weather right now I said I was
gonna play this let me play this and
then we'll see what I do next
take the night and then pile up on D
that's my plan
pile up on D clean be 697 Knight f5 this
would come with a tempo on the bishop I
want to secure my Knights position on f5
as well I do that with h5 this next I
don't know that could really be defended
I guess Knight e 2 is needed should I
really pick off that pine the rook
that's this b7 pond where there's that
move let's do this that was a move I
shouldn't have done then okay my Queens
gonna have to run home she is officially
running home this Knight needs to go
let's get this rook here and then kicked
that night away very soon if he's kicked
away now I make use of a5 I'm gonna get
into c4 and there's not really an issue
okay that maybe I could play on this
this side of the board somehow I don't
know how I should capture either maybe
this way let's do this first they make
you get my other Knight to f5 let's do
this okay now I know I don't want to do
I want to get my knight to e6 and then
here pressure on both of these points my
bishop could do something else should I
do that
I don't know it's to defend this pawn
and I don't want to play here I don't
think maybe I can keep that night away I
shouldn't have done that I'm dropping
that pawn now I don't have any time
didn't have much time there it's pawn
push no matter what nothing no matter
what after they capture okay back to
Turman
six-six and a bunch of two's still very
very early very early here I was not I
was feeling well at the beginning of the
stream but now I'm drifting um
that's castle why am I saying that am I
saying that so I have an excuse I know
are you saying that in case he loses he
has an alibi
is that the plan my queen is dead queen
is dead Knight takes pawn trade Queens
first you know I feel about the Queen
trades ok support my Center get my king
involved my king involved hit this rook
maintain this pond it boxes out the
night at the bishop okay that actually
scares me
okay the Brooke taking here would have
been better cuz it's hitting at be just
back up
what's my light square bishop even doing
let's get him active right here's a fork
but I could get out of it with a check
rook check needed it wasn't played looks
gonna come off
okay let's post up on the seventh there
and grab this pawn get rid of that
tricky Knight he can't be uh can't be
saved candy here no matter what here no
matter what
get the bishops off here stop that King
stop that King from getting active they
resigned back to tournament twelve six
okay twelve and a bunch of sixes mr.
suave so the guy I don't want to see so
the guy I don't want to see I played him
in the last turn I didn't I trade Queens
trade Queens
three queens King up I'm fine with that
since it's an endgame
can my [ __ ] about get my rook on c8 and
then target c2 maybe some expansion my
knight on c4 double up on the C file
maybe get this Knight out of here I
think this pawn really gonna be taken
probably get trapped wouldn't it just in
case just in case right here and then
tricky stuff okay that'll be checked I
want to pin that night take here and
then pin at night and then get to where
actually now I'm gonna take this pun I
want to get I don't want the position to
simplify too much I didn't even see that
there there's a knight check right there
my King needs needs to come over King
here King here Bishop is actually
guarding that King right here pawn push
hard push pawn push take that I guess if
I gave a check I just dropped c4 so
let's do this this and then pawn push I
guess hey give me that rook and then how
do I convert this is this a one King and
pawn endgame yeah it is
oh okay let's come over here time issues
actually okay oh this is working yeah
okay this is working outside passed pawn
wins no he's passed though I forgot that
that pond was passed let's freak about
that guy that's that wouldn't have been
good
actually I'm ready to forget about him
still oh let me break him up like this
that's the way to do it I almost forgot
about that
this isn't even a win I need some time
burners then we go in the other
direction
I need some time burners time burners I
need to get the W this is totally a draw
I can't no no no come on yes that was
such a draw man whoa how does somebody
have 30 how does somebody have 30 sorry
for the sniffles watch out for them here
we go ah man I totally forgot about that
C pond he was past my ponds were doubled
my ponds were doubled on the and that
rook on the other rook file okay I got a
hang on oh my dark square bishop is this
guy doing 20 okay this Knight out of
there
challenged the bishop my Queen can't get
chased away my queens in a good spot no
she's not
I could have gotten this pond this
Knight out of there get into d6 do
something night this is gonna be deadly
isn't it oh I got the Queen they're
gonna resign they resign back to term in
30 20 2012 oh man I have to play more
aggressive I think here's this guy Wow
here's a beast echo we've played before
he's given me beatings before it's been
a while though it's been a while all
right
area's zodiac here we go here we go stay
focused somehow stay focused now okay
capture towards that center and then I
could get a d5 if I have two pawns
controlling that square a6 b5 I would
have done that even if there wasn't a
bishop there okay now the B file maybe I
can make use of but I'm still of course
looking at h2 I doubt my opponent will
fall for that but don't doubt that I
won't
keep trying for I'm not even threatening
anything there I'm threatening this pawn
hit this pawn da deaths weakened Oh Oh
what am i doing
ah I don't even react to that threat
that night could be taken I want to take
care now I'm gonna run away I have
discovered get this Knight out of here
so my light-square bishop could finally
see the board get rid of this night he
is a giant pain he has to go he
definitely has to go can I get at this
square somehow look up and over look
maybe getting at that square my knight
wants to do what my knight wants to be
right here to get rid of this night
the knight moves I can maybe get a g2
tonight right here take my knight just
want to remove them oh the Queen you
give a check why did I allow that okay
oh that nights gonna be taken and on the
roof though if that happens open up the
H file maybe I'm on the rook take this
pawn just take that I was ready to
Castle queenside I can't Castle
queenside my king is kind of not in a
good spot
oh they could just take that pawn they
don't have any time it doesn't matter
there's no time let's watch out for me
just watch out for me no time back to
tournament 47 or no 49 Nona fries it's
been a while Nona fries right it has
definitely been a while been a lot of a
while since I was paired up it's no no
okay
I have the dark square bishop I want to
keep the Queen's on the board if I did
that right away I think there's a
forcing Queen trig stop castling there's
a bishop here if Queen there okay and
the light square bishop
okay break this open am I gonna get no
okay let's let's defend this my bishops
I'm protected over here okay I have that
fortunately there is a check I could
play here secure stuff there's a check I
have to block with my queen let me just
get out for that same file oh my
goodness I just dropped a piece you know
what I need oh man
the dark square weaknesses with that
last move dark square weaknesses oh man
I gotta try something dangerous I have
to try something very dangerous yes I
got the Queen oh man that's exactly what
I needed
yeah oh man
luck is on my side once again woah play
here pawn push looking for me next Wow
lucky lucky Wow Wow here no matter what
back to tournament land 47 42 42 I
dropped my bishop on f5 Wow I didn't
even realize the knight moved and the
bishop on its home square c8 was hitting
my bishop I didn't realized there was
tension between those guys okay okay
development drop back if it's attacked
okay I have a good center advance my
center clean east 7 push forward not so
fast though let's pin this pawn defend
this pawn keep this night out of here I
think get rid of that night
Queens ready to come over to well a a
five or something on that night twice
okay keep the night away here oh man
this is a little scary
oh I'm dropping that pun okay this
should still be alright
Queen trade Queen trade okay I'm fine
with this actually bishop pair is
actually some compensation it's actually
some compensation let's do this that's a
good move upon push is a good move I
should have been more aggressive with my
bishop here that night's gonna kill me
oh boy
that's going to h5 let's come over here
before it's too late
it's very easy to go wrong here I don't
even know what I'm doing at that move
I'm hitting the rook they missed it with
check okay to drop back we're right here
otherwise I dropped this politics I take
care that night was way too powerful
that Bishop gonna defendant I'm on this
pawn I want need to break down this
structure they didn't they didn't card
that pawn time situation defend here
defend here I'm here with my king get
this pawn rook check the rook is kind of
out of play
hang on where's my time I don't have
much of it all the way
defend stuff defend I could have taken
that bish up you got them now they don't
have time time burners time burners I
get the brook I got the rook back over
here checks well they're down a time oh
man 56 56 55 42 buh-buh-buh-buh is here
in town he's in town
okay Sicilian dragon know that was
probably a mountain that's got to be a
mouse liver you don't do that I've done
that before
who else has done that I have definitely
done that 96 is winning the house the
farm the farm f7 next regardless pawn
first and then target f7 I'm gonna take
that just okay I have this covered
because there to defend just finish
development get rid of the dark square
Bishop maybe it rid of this Knight
actually he's he's the best piece for
black get rid of that I'll just take the
bishop he was free this is this is close
to being like a helped me clean here
it's gonna be me it's a main to threat
pawn push I could take okay matin - you
have to you have to block with the pot
and then it's made on f6 right that's me
back to term in 73 72 72 52 rehtaeh okay
14 minutes remaining
14 minutes okay Knight g4 my opponent is
stopping that idea still stopping that
idea my pawns are under build on that
night twice pawn push next the knight
has to go to not-so-great square okay
go for a queen trade my bishops come
right to life
stop that bishop from developing to a
decent square I don't know if I even
want a castle actually what I want to do
is get my night to g3 g3 is gonna be
very powerful dark square bishop
exchange bad stuff can happen quickly
let me just pin this night my opponent
is having to work out of some nasty pins
Bishop takes pawn not available because
the pressure on the night the h-file can
open up a could be turn on to be a mate
very soon you back up I still want this
somehow now now the Knights gonna take I
should have just take in the night okay
if that Knight moves it's close to main
somehow I could take on the h3 very
important detail very important detail
and now I'm just looking for the other
rook although the night this is guarded
this is guarded and we're gonna be
having made on h2 let me give a check
divert the night away from attacking my
rook and then do this now I'm pretty
sure it's an unavoidable main could have
also taken here with check and then
delivered me that was more direct back
to Turman ninety six ninety three ninety
ninety a lot of game remaining Bobo
again okay maybe I can throw my H pawn
down and open the H file because of g6
something to maybe considering these
fast games let's see can I rip this file
open or maybe have this pawn act as a
thorn no now I want to oh I was gonna
target g6 if g6 was even there it's not
there I'm dropping this though dropping
that pun it's not being taken you grab
that with check if the King goes back
here I get the Queen can give a check is
this gonna be me I think it is King
takes Knight f4 is lights out okay
that's what check I think now you could
take it and run away he's not running
away okay that's this is gonna be where
is the main
just take the night and then it's made
over here it's gonna be mate back to
tournament 110 110 ninety six ninety
three ninety less than 12 minutes
remaining William B William B I can
assure you knows all about the fishing
pole do I even try is the big question
he's cannot defend hundreds of times
here he goes again
right after h2 okay and all right so
this game is not gonna finish anytime
soon alright keep this pin try and stay
as annoying as possible okay I thought
maybe tonight here right away let's keep
this night away and then maybe target
the beep on very soon in fact if the B
file opens up it's very difficult to
contend or I can test the B file cuz I
control I control the B the B 1 square
now the night is hey I'm looking to get
rid of what so let me hit this pawn I
can hit it again as well I think I want
to get rid of this one so I can move my
pawn and kick this night away pawn push
I can make use of the light squares let
me get out of the way so this night
could be kicked I can also get a rip to
the second and pin that Bishop take the
bishop take the knight I could also give
a check a wedding material here and also
the rook I could give a check if the
rook blocks it's not blocking I got this
and it's a mating one thread on h2 I can
also grab the Queen and I should have
done that to check now I have it my head
resign check here no matter what the
rook is pinned let's try over here
actually
now here mate in one - no matter what
back to tournament 131 16 113 90 88 less
than 10 minutes remaining nap 3e for nap
3 I can assure you knows all about the
fishing pole stuff - I've done that
against this player several times
they've never found four
never okay all right
can I get my majority going on the
queenside I have a four to three
majority so let me try to get these
pawns rolling so I'm gonna supercharge
the queenside might even want to start
out with c5 first I'm looking for made
over here let's stop that I push next
let's do it right now
pawn push can't allow upon to get to d6
there's no way I want to get up with d4
my night is defended although playing
here could be a bit annoying whoa whoa
whoa whoa I have to run I have to pack
up and run I have this guarded
fortunately there's back rank mates all
soft the knight moves I get back rank
stuff back rank stuff but not if my king
is right here I wouldn't have that
available okay let's bump up so that I
could keep some coordination here maybe
my rook swing over here is a possibility
my king over and I don't want to go too
far away with my rook otherwise they're
skewers so what how do you defend I
still have this defended let's do this I
feel like I'm gonna be dropping stuff
soon yeah I'm gonna be dropping stuff I
gotta take with my clean otherwise
there's a skewer Bishop takes Knight
I just want to defend they don't have it
oh they must lift it they don't have any
time either box out the night keep that
night boxed out very easy to go wrong
but they're down on time bishops gonna
give it a check no it's not their down
time 151 36 Oh less than 8 minutes
remaining
Tariq Tariq here okay less than 8 less
than 8 capture towards the center ok
and stop tonight might be five stuff or
the bishop coming out there I still
might want to go for that no it's the
transition over here on the queenside my
dark square Bishop out to an aggressive
post so now I'm actually right here I
could take on h2 with check see how they
defend take an h2 it's check I have to
watch out for sacrifices on this square
but I could get out of it because Bishop
takes h2 it's check can also take this
[ __ ] up with check so there's no do
this
there's no tricky stuff on b5 at that
point yeah the Queen's actually I'm just
winning this pawn now putting that pine
I have to watch out a little bit for
this if it's hit and they just move it
and okay
you do this watch out for pawn push my
queen isn't a good spot Queen might be
challenged fine with the Queen shade I
don't know if I even want to castle just
you sit this rook see what it wants to
do first and then I'll take this pawn
let's take this pawn I'm gonna go on
Castle but if I get upon the h3 it's a
giant thorn that should not be allowed
because that opens up that light square
diagonal even allowing this is fine
because now the King has to run
somewhere out in the open so let me just
drop back to defend hit the Queen
oh the Queen's gonna come here with the
check I missed that she's not doing that
with check now let's try this I could
take the rook if rook takes rook now I'm
out of the pin actually I've been out of
the pin for a while haven't I but I
would have had to give up my queen where
does that mean where is that made of
dodge these checks here dodge the checks
okay they're down on time back to
tournament 170 151 155 minutes 50
seconds remaining okay efore night here
this guy gonna move
oh I shouldn't approve that okay here we
go here we go here we go
I was uh my opponent is just moving a
little bit slow I keep thinking it's my
move but they're they're just going a
little bit slower than I was used to
yeah from playing those other games
uh-oh
light-square weaknesses I had like a
mate and two Queen here ah I should've
gotten on this diagonal much much sooner
let's try it now I have to take this
knife first cuz there be a pawn block
pawn takes I think it's a meetin - Queen
could give a check I could block though
pawn takes mate in two or three pawn
push I think would even lead to me yeah
okay it's a good move I think give a
check Queen e2 like a castle Castle
queenside it should have been much much
simpler okay the Queen's are officially
off the board take my queen all right
okay I could get that night as soon as
my bishop drops back I'm on this night
this was not the fastest way to victory
at all dark-squared bishop Soph I have a
time edge still on that night got the
night I'm on the rook drop back I think
no matter what and then just queenside
castle no matter what I don't want any
time to come off the clock no matter
what queenside castle unless it's
illegal
that one was illegal King up rook here
defending that pun discovered check on
takes pawn discovered check - watch out
here anything actually right here time
burner time burners no time they don't
check the server okay back to tournament
191 seventy 14 games each we could get
paired up one more game at least maybe
another one they resigned back to
tournament +10 201 71-68
here we go
315 keep this closed here push maybe and
get my queen to e2 pawn push maybe next
and then he becomes a giant pest for the
the Queen side pieces is difficult to
get queenside developed let's see oh man
if I took that I would have got made it
let's [ __ ] you made it here oh man I
need to get rid of that dark square
bishop maybe I could attack ahh-choo
Queen trade even at the cost of this c3
pawn just get the Queen's off the board
get those Queens off the board my queen
is running out of squares just come here
to defend hopefully okay take this and
then I want to get rid of that dark
square bishop it's a monster here pawn
push is happening soon isn't it get rid
of this and now get my knight here doing
something get that Bishop out my queen
okay my queen needs to come over here
pawn push get over here
so that there's no mate I want to give a
check yeah I should have done that first
give a check first and then whoa where's
that King going I take care I want to
get rid of that c3 pawn c3 pawn needs to
go actually this bishop needs to go okay
for a second I was actually considering
just not taking that bishop and getting
the that pond because it's a giant thorn
I'm defending against me
I just want to give a check and then get
that pawn get rid of the pond and that
there's not gonna be any mates as soon
as that uh as soon as that is they're
back up stay coordinated now right here
I'm just looking for coordination
coordination me this pond throwing some
checks here actually they're gonna be
able to clean if they want it they got a
queen wow that was bad technique on my
part they're down on time fortunately
222 1053 seconds
Nona fries fifty seconds remaining here
we go
I'm not paired up with that guy that's
in second nope
so if that kind of wins I think then I'm
gonna end up with second I shouldn't
have done that move let's try this okay
I'm not even showing it what the result
of that move is what does it even do
what does that even do clean here
queenside castle I guess throw my rooks
on the G file it's just not gonna finish
is it the okay why did I open up that
file maybe I could get at age two
there's only eight seconds anything just
call it am I am I gonna get first it
says it's completed why don't I get what
did I get what did I get what I can't
win I get first oh oh if that guy what a
one eye wandering out first ah man I am
exhausted let me close out to twenty two
fourteen oh he must have dropped backer
so now this guy jumped ahead to twenty
two fourteen to ten 188 188 it was a
close one for I think like second and
third actually anything really any one
of us could have won up there Wow
alright good games oh I am tired okay